Stephen strange
might I offer you some advice forget
everything that you think you long
your man looking at the world through a
keyhole
you've spent your life trying to widen
it
you won't save the night
what if I told you
reality is one of many
believe in fairytales about chakras or
energy or the power of belief
you wonder what I see in your future
possibility
why are you doing this
so much you don't know
hey youtubers so we finally got some
darker strange footage let's break it
down already from the level of weirdness
you can tell that this is going to
change the reality of Marvel films going
forward now remember he crosses into
other dimensions they're not talking
about the multiverse so it's not quite
the same thing Tilda Swinton as the
ancient one looking awesome tells him
there are other realities as it jumps
back and forth between his time before
he got into his accident and after if
you don't know anything about Doctor
Strange he's this world-famous surgeon
who ends up smashing his hands in a car
accident that you actually see here he
has to find meaning and he finds it
through magic through the ancient one
the voice-over that's saying forget
everything you know that's chiwetel
ejiofor as Baron Mordo who's actually a
big Doctor Strange villain but probably
not in this movie Mads Mikkelsen is
going to be the big villain to this
movie and it's still a mystery as to who
he's playing it doesn't look like
Dormammu even though Dormammu is the
lord of the Dark Dimension he's kind of
like Mephisto they're just like
different versions of devil like
character some of the most powerful
beings in the Marvel Universe with the
exception of fan OHS when he's wearing
the Infinity Gauntlet rachel mcadams
character looks like she might end up
being night nurse she's just a person
that treats other people in the Marvel
Universe when they need help and they
can't go to a real Hospital like say
spider-man gets hurt he needs medical
attention you can't take him to a normal
hospital because they'll find out his
identity so they take people like that
to night nurse because we see her in the
hospital scrubs it looks like she's
gonna be a through-line like a
relationship from before his accident to
his time as sorcerer supreme and that's
what's happening at the end of the
trailer he's walking up the steps to his
sanctum sanctorum so the trailer covers
the whole gamut like it covers him as a
doctor
getting into the accident finding the
ancient one learning the mystical arts
then becoming sorcerer supreme one of
the problems in the comics originally
when he was first created by Stan Lee he
had a very Tony Stark type of origin
story he looks very much like Tony Stark
that's why they do jokes like this
facial hair bros for life if you show
this to someone who didn't know anything
about comics they might think that these
two guys were brothers but that's really
where the similarity ends yeah there
used to be genius douchebags now they're
genius heroes trying to save all of time
and space if you know anything about
Doctor Strange you know he gets really
trippy so that's why we're seeing a lot
of inception a lot of matrix stuff going
on here so I can't wait to see him
interact with the other Avengers now
like I said Maz Mick
sin is gonna be the main villain of the
film all the Kevin Feige has said is
that he's the leader of a rival sect
which is why it might not be Dormammu
might be someone else there are a whole
bunch of big villains in the Doctor
Strange comics but this seems like
someone who's either relatively small
that they've turned into a big thing for
the movies or somebody new they've
created for the movies specifically but
when it comes to big villains Marvel
usually sticks pretty close to the
comics even if it changes minor details
about backstory or Colossus over things
the rumor is is he could be playing cos
Silius which is a deep cut from like the
1960s and the Doctor Strange comics but
I guess we'll find out what we might see
though is shades of bigger villains as
they battle each other Dormammu is the
easy one he's like a Thanos level
villain there Shuma gorath that's a
really trippy octopus looking creature I
would think of the name of simplicity
they would probably go for Dormammu over
the giant eyeball tentacle monster but
it remains to be seen so they might end
up using Dormammu during the Doctor
Strange movies the same way they used
Thanos with the Avengers movies just
kind of weave him in and then make him
the big bad of a much much later film we
do have to address Benedict
Cumberbatch's accent he's using an
American accent which sounds a little
bit weird because in most of the roles
that he's played he's used his British
accent so that might take you a couple
minutes to get used to but I think it'll
be fine he's one of the best actors on
the planet before they signed him Marvel
had been going after him for years Kevin
Feige was like we've been trying to get
him for forever until they actually
signed paper on ink but let me know what
your favorite thing about the trailer is
really I just love how trippy it looks
it's taking the standard superhero fare
that we've gotten with the normal Marvel
films phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 and it's
kind of flipping it on its head so if
you really liked how ant-man was weird
and different from a lot of the other
big Marvel films this is just gonna
double down on that kind of Awesome
weirdness I do feel like I'm gonna have
to do more explainer videos for Doctor
Strange stuff than any other Marvel
comic because people understand who Iron
Man is that's pretty straight forward
you know who the hook is you know who
Thor is Doctor Strange gets into this
weird psychedelic territory but it's a
whole universe worth of characters that
we just have not seen in any of these
other Marvel films yet so there's any
videos that you guys want me to start
with when it comes to Doctor Strange
stuff just let me know in the comments
but for the most part the movies gonna
have all the Doctor Strange core
characters like Wong we're gonna have
Nicodemus West will probably have some
other Avengers stuff going on in the
background I think they want this to be
relatively self-contained
kind of like ant-man was so I'll have
some references to other Marvel things
that have been going on while Doctor
Strange has been alive but by the end
don't be surprised if they start to
reference stuff that's going to be
happening during Avengers infinity war
they just confirmed a whole bunch of
Marvel stuff in the last couple of days
so I'll do a new video for that it'll be
Avengers Captain America Civil War
related
while you guys wait for that you can
click here for my Suicide Squad trailer
video from the other night and you can
click here for the new Game of Thrones
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight